welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse an Avengers the end game was an
epic crossover event so packed with
details so easy to miss because you know
we were busy saluting America's ass our
abilities for overwatch has finally
arrived and I actually somehow found new
stuff
in this movie so I'm gonna mix it with
stuff that we have found before in our
like infinite number breakdowns of the
bass and compiled it all into one video
for you here we go we open on the farm
of Clint Barton wearing that ankle
monitor after Civil War teaching archery
to his daughter Lyla played by
co-director Joe Russo's daughter Ava you
see we're going mm-hmm okay let's worry
about how you get there these opening
words introduced in games theme of
Destiny on any life trajectory first
choose your targets then chart the
course in chess your endgame can't be a
chaotic scramble to survive it must be
an exact decisive series of moves toward
your specific preset goals the avengers
defeat and infinity war finally gave
them that why that target a reason to
fight something to avenge finally and
now with that why they can finally worry
about the how they get to their
destinies interesting details in the
sound design the moment of the snap you
can hear rumbles of thunder babe just
like we heard him what Condon infinity
war
and bright before the dusting several
birds are chirping look at you but then
right after the snap that chirping has
lessened let's go violet right after
banner reverses a snap later on the
first return light forms they see are
birds that immediately get incinerating
with Davis arrives flint mourns as dust
family with Nate's baseball glove
visible in the background later on in
the test this is the same glove that
Clint brings back the 1e holds dear the
one that he was probably clinging to for
years and years the test glove before
they make their own real glove and by
taking the baseball glove probably
created a branch timeline without
baseball who cares now remember Nate was
named after Natasha the life whom
Clint's trades to get his kids and white
back and then after losing her Clint
Don's her signature glove piece the
widow's bite from there forward the
storytelling fits like a you get it the
Marvel Studios title card erased all the
Avengers who were dusted along with
ant-man because he as good as dusted at
this point sorry but we want you to also
notice how in the Marvel letters they
scrubbed all these people from their
past scenes and replace the backgrounds
so instead of Doctor Strange there's an
empty synced of an empty portal instead
of Wanda in age of Ultron there's an
empty sokovia doorway they had to
reanimate those doors instead of Pelican
there's an empty rooftop on Lagos
instead of rocket and baby Groot there's
just rocket in my favorite instead of
Gamora in the M they use the bones of
egos children from guardians vol 2 all
these characters Tony and nebula flick a
foil football foreshadowing how Tony
will flick ant-man later and the way the
stark gauntlet was a kind of football
that they have to hand off in the final
battle Tony survives for three weeks
without dying from thirst maybe because
back in Iron Man 2 he upgraded his armor
to filter his urine into drinkable water
he's just keep I know it has a
filtration system he could drink that
work he makes the recording don't post
it on social media it's gonna be a real
tearjerker calling back his opening
words in the first Ironman I don't want
to see you son
and he sells pepper poacher calling back
the moment he made pepper CEO and Iron
Man - it's you it's always been you 24
shadows his own death here might be
Nate's here from the damaged right side
of the helmet just like his own future
damaged right side and the music is the
same as his funeral music when Tony rips
off his chest reactor you can see the
circular scar from his earlier circular
implant which when you think about it
somehow went through his sternum and rib
cage Oh Thor takes his first steps
toward + sides by carbo-loading with
rolls and beer from creature comforts
it's a local Georgia brewery Antoni
tells rocket honestly it's as exact
second I thought you were build-a-bear
maybe I am
yeah rocket probably doesn't get the
reference but he also doesn't know what
he is mysterious origin probably gonna
be settled in volume 3 Carol offers or
help you guys take care of him they'll
bring in Missouri and elixir when I come
back the saurians are an ancient
humanoid race from Marvel Comics and
then Rhodey calls her out where the hell
have you been all this time there are a
lot of other planets in the universe and
unfortunately they didn't have you guys
who you looking for this actually later
on on the benitar okay who here hasn't
been to space
why yeah Carol chuckles right after
hearing roadies armored arm go up he's
not in her eyeline yeah some
satisfaction for her as the more
experienced world Savior these people
haven't even left the atmosphere or
maybe she doesn't have to see him
because she Minds has been he thought
they heard another
[Music]
this is either audio pareidolia look it
up of for exhaling that sounds like the
words I have telepathy
or maybe the most overpowered Avenger
has got another skill that she's gonna
show up in Captain Marvel to the movie
title is revealed down a bit compared to
the main of interesting that we've heard
before
reflecting how these Avengers are facing
Thanos without their phone numbers and
house of s trees brass section probably
suffered from snap those poor poor
trombone errs a close-up of perhaps I as
he leaves Earth's atmosphere for the
first time matches a closeup of Tony's
eye and Avengers his first time of space
as he fell back to earth just like how
in this movie these two Avengers
destinies are Criss crossing Tony's
endpoint is eternal rest caps in point
is Peggy you know if Thanos is in point
as Thor going for the head finally which
younger Thanos gets a view of but he
refuses to let his destiny play out
naturally that is Destiny Fulfilled cap
later says no I saw a pod of whales when
I was coming over the bridge in the
Hudson it's fewer ships cleaner water
which are visible and audible here
his sport group features cameos from
co-director Joe Russo and fan OHS comics
creator jim Starlin in the banner over
their heads memorializes Matthew
Haggerty who was the second assistant
director for infinity warned in game
Scott Lang storage unit is labeled six
one six a nod to earth-616 the primary
Marvel Comics universe that MCU earth
one nine nine nine nine nine might exist
alongside the Marvel multiverse
multiverse that gets saved by a rat here
Russo community pal King John cameos
reading the terminal beach by
post-apocalyptic fiction writer JG
Ballard actually features a short story
called endgame now the names on the San
Francisco memorial walls include shout
outs to various crew people including
visual effects supervisor Dan Dell you
tell you is up there with the directors
and screenwriters in determining what
these movies were Joe Russo's son basil
his daughter Sophia and her boyfriend
cameo as observers here look away
dismisses a report net it's an
earthquake under the ocean we handle it
by not handling it long speculated to be
a possible name or set up which the
writers recently hinted might be true on
the chair beside that our ballet pointe
shoes suggesting she's returning to her
ballet from a Red Room days of history
we'll probably see more of than Black
Widow rocket now wears a red scarf the
same one that Peter quill used to wear
everyone sad God asks them have either
of you guys ever studied quantum physics
only to make conversation
yeah she's referring to her time with
banner probably keeping her buddy calm
with nerdy physics talking you know hand
petting Tony's farms shooting locations
actually only about a hundred yards from
where they shot the Battle of Wakanda
you actually see part of that field in
the background Tony actually mentioned
this farm retirement and his daughter
Morgan in past films this should take a
page at a Barton's book mill pepper a
farm hope nobody blows it up last night
I dreamt we had a kid so real we named
him after your eccentric Uncle Bob what
was his name works
Morgan Morgan wears the helmet pepper of
course later works for a rescue armored
it's fine actually
mom never wears anything I buy her yeah
in Iron Man 3 Tony did get pepper a
necklace made out of his chest retinol
that she has not worn since but you know
who could blame her Tony tells the
others quantum fluctuation messes with
the Planck scale which then triggers the
Dortch proposition can we agree on that
he's referring to David Deutsch - a big
proponent of the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics Tony
is
warning that quantum time meddling
causes multiverse complications
essentially what Mordo warned temporal
manipulations can create branches in
time unstable dimensional openings
special paradoxes time loops smart hulks
black rimmed glasses were detailed with
scuff marks and thumb prints
you know maybe wipe those big ol fingers
after wrapping sausage is a pancake
spanner Joe Russo's kid Leah Anthony
Russo son Julian and their nephew Augie
cameo as the fans and again another
youth actor and other lens look directly
into my soul Tony's new outlook on time
travel comes after finding the photo
with Peter his certificate is inverted
which right after the movie come out
some clever fans pointed out this helped
Tony crack the code one last shim before
we pack it in for the night
this time in the shape of a mobius strip
inverted please other details with this
photo that I noticed it's behind a photo
of Howard which is the paternal Reunion
Tony still needs closure on which helps
him realize his paternal relationship
with the surrogate son he left behind
Peter and they're both making rabbit
ears or the peace sign which reminds
Tony of the peace he still needs to make
with cab I just want peace
I'm fu 3000 actually came from Robert
Downey jr. zone kids and Morgan said
this after Tony said I love you tons a
ton is 2,000 pounds so Morgan is
basically saying I love you a ton and a
half the answer folks have also done the
math suggesting the runtimes of the full
infinity saga add up to three thousand
minutes but Tony keeps these math jokes
going but she loves me 3,000 who does
she know you were somewhere below six to
nine hundred branch oh yeah Tony's kind
of making a sixty-nine joke there which
I use to speculate new master 69 could
be Tony
there was a fake meme suggest Enoch was
confirmed as Wang but that's so very
Wang polkas is a pencil on the controls
because his fingers are too fat and they
reached the baby he'll grow
free Scott back I see this is an
absolute win yeah banners on to
something with he'll grow because they
just locked into immortality Boehner
could reach himself to his younger form
back before he got the gamma radiation
you know when he looks like Ed Norton
new Asgard is in tonsberg norway where
the Asgardians fought the frost giants
at 4:1 and also where Odin's church was
and cap won
and where Odin died and Ragnarok Hulk
weighs down the truck because he's too
fat in the background is that Sekar
gladiator who left cigar with Korg and
Ragnarok and you can also see how in
that pile they are brewing Asgardian ale
that Thor always wears gloves to hide
the wrists themes of Hemsworth fat suit
Korg is wearing the same Hawaiian shirt
that Taika Waititi wore at comic-con and
when Thor stands in front of the TV tyka
has to lean over to see his fortnight
name is Ragnarok and role and later
fortnight CEO Donal mustard cameos as a
source work in their home our candy Pez
dispensers for Hulk and Iron Man and of
the bookshelf our titles like small
group decision-making which you know
Thor has learned to do with The Avengers
over the years and do it by Jerry Rubin
that cover of which talks about a war
between generations and creating a new
society on the ashes of the old as new
Asgard has had to do after Ragnarok and
stay in half of everyone turn to ash in
Tokyo about half of the buildings lights
are off and there's this long take that
shows Ronan Hawkeye killing the
criminals but it does not cut until
Clint cuts the bosses neck as if Clint
was holding his breath this whole time
was only able to exhale when his blood
thirst was quenched and speaking of
quenched when Clint returns from the
trial mission Scott brings him orange
slices because he knows Pym tech can be
physically draining does anyone have any
orange slices the word puts eyedrops
only in his left eye since his right eye
is a prosthetic replacement given to him
by rocket after he'll have punched it
out Hulk eats a hunka-hunka burning
fudge Wong's favorite Ben and Jerry's
ice cream from Infinity Ward hunka hunka
burning footage is our favorite that's a
thing and nebula is struggling to use
the chopsticks their quantum suits
combine Tech from three sources then see
you nanobots from Star tech quantum
access from Pym tech and these blue
visors which come from krei tech used by
the guardians of galaxy and by Captain
Marvel and when they throw in their
hands the overhead image reflects Tony's
arc reactor which of course becomes his
tombstone in the funeral in Asgard Thor
has a can of beer without meaning that
he took this with him in his quantum
suit of course he would his mother free
good catches him oh hi
remember the Battle of heroine when I
got hit in the face with the broadsword
he's calling back that battle that he
chatted with Lady SIF about in dark
world
I remember you celebrated
of Huracan so much that you nearly
stopped at the second and freaka
recognizes that he's from the future
because as Loki pointed out in Ragnarok
Asgardian witches can see the future was
I supposed to know can't see into the
future a little which rocket steals the
ether and of course Thor also refers to
him as rabbit suggesting that rocket
just looks like a rabbit to all his
Guardians Tony lands in Avengers tower
retracting his armor from the feet up to
land more softly
Hulk clenches his fist at Loki as he
always does he did it then Ragnarok when
Loki pass him he's a guy now there's a
lot of sexual innuendo with Scott I
think you look great cap as far as I'm
concerned that's America's ass I'm going
inside you and when he sticks out his
but if you were to caption his line
flick me in all caps like a comic book
bubble season definitely present teen
for something else
yes PN's Matthew berry cameos as a
SHIELD agent the lobby right around when
Thor says lunch and then as god I'm
sorry you are
lunch is referring to their famous war
Motown
now they cleverly used the fact that
2012 Tony hadn't yet upgraded to
seamless nanotech following Scotts
infiltration and civil war in order to
jailbreak his suit here but also the use
the fact that following whiplash Tony's
mark 7 could sustain an electric jolt
from Thor to bring him back from that
cardiac arrest tony is a well-versed
student of his own history we get a
great call back to the elevator moment
and Winter Soldier with the same tense
whooshes
[Music]
but again it is not the fight that makes
cap a good soldier it is his ability to
sidestep the fight
Loki's cap impression of course call
back the Dark Worlds but also it sets up
2012 cap thinking his future self is
Loki and fighting them I can do this all
day yeah I know I know these two were
actually longtime Marvel stuntmen Sam
Hara grape uu just directed Chris
Hemsworth and extraction and his brother
Daniel older cap ends up beating his
younger self they end up in a headlock
just like his fight with Bucky and
Winter Soldier but older captains I'm
catching them off guard by telling him
Bucky's alive just as crossbones day to
catch me off guard in Civil War Bucky
[Music]
you know navigating mysteries as
perplexing as time travel must feel like
a maddening blank space with that
blinking cursor you're just praying and
answer pops into much like those empty
promo code feels when we shop online
just taunting us with deals that we're
missing out on well thanks to honey
promo code FOMO is a thing of the past
honey is the free browser extension that
automatically finds promo codes and
applies them to your cart so let's say
you're shopping online at Target or Game
Stop Domino's wherever when you check
out this little box drops down and all
you have to do is click apply coupons
and you wait a few seconds for it to
scan the promo codes from across the
internet and then watch the prices drop
recently I was shopping for an herb
garden planter for my little patio space
and I found one on target.com and honey
saved me over ten bucks I mean I was
gonna buy the cleaner anyways but now I
have a place to slowly murder chives and
an extra ten dollars new rock stars fans
that have already downloaded honey in
the past using our promo code have
already saved themselves almost three
hundred thousand dollars collectively
that's enough to buy a couple boxes of
scraps honey supports over 30,000 stores
online including Walmart j.crew and
Newegg if you don't already have honey
you could be straight-up missing out on
free money honey it's literally free and
it installs in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting us here at new rock
stars get honey for free at join
honeycomb slash new rock stars that's
join honey calm slash new rock stars
Loki steals the tesseract and lives on
on Disney Plus and so they have to jump
back again I know for a fact they were
there hey what are we doing who I know
what's in New Jersey zero four zero four
zero seven seven Cuse me nine seven
though
April 7th 1970 is six weeks before
Tony's birthday of May 29 1917 Tony
knows his father was at this base after
reading Howard's notes in Iron Man 2
which included details about his work
with the tesseract and Tony must know
hank pym parted ways with howard in 1987
and maybe that the tesseract would have
been given over to project Pegasus and
when he lost him by then Stan Lee makes
his final MCU cameo dressed as himself
in an old seventies photo that exists
his bumper sticker reads enough said
just Stan's soapbox sign-off but his
license plate is 420 lro maybe 420 let's
roll one cap steals the uniform of
Captain Roscoe a nod to Roscoe Symons
who took over the mantle of Captain
America in the Nomad era community actor
Evette Nicole Brown cameos along with
the movie's co-writer Christopher Markus
is a SHIELD agent Howard Stark appears
looking for dr. Zola have you seen him
the VFX team actually snuck in a cameo
by arnim zola's face on a screen in the
background which would be an early
version of his AI algorithm before it
took over the shield servers Howard
tells Tony should don't pull a bit of
advice that Tony later takes shaking the
stones loose off Thanos with nanobots
rather than tried to pull the whole
gauntlet off his hand if he tried to do
on Titan cap steals the extra Pym
particles from paying slab passing the
old design of ant man's helmets and he
gets another glimpse of destiny Peggy
Carter and it's hard to hear but they
were discussing a guy named Braddock
possibly Brian Braddock Captain Britain
from an alternate comics universe James
D'Arcy plays Edwin Jarvis as he did
agent Carter behind them on a bench is
an extra who I think looks a lot like
Loki and in my head Canon will always be
nebula and rody intercept Peter quill
and Morag but they don't use quills
gravity snare to take the Power Stone
like he did in guardians one said nebula
burns her robot hands they do this to
give us a visual clue
later on if it being evil nebula with an
undamaged hand who opens up the quantum
tunnel to let Thanos through in the
scree
revealed that in 2014 gamora nebulous
combatants were korbinites the race of
beta ray bill down on the planet corbin
explosions blackout half of the city
don't really stick into that 50% aren't
they they know Slater uncovers the time
I stand sees his destiny Avengers unruly
wretches the word unruly he's calling
back the others description of the
Avengers Flint tells me Tasha a long way
from Budapest I'll be back there lying
in Avengers Widow film will be set
partially in Budapest though that will
be set in years after that line and
Avengers in a way we're gonna get some
answers on Budapest red skull great some
etosha don't have Ivan great son of
Edith Edith not to be confused with Tony
Stark's Edith Edith Barton was Clint's
mom who in the comics protected him from
an abusive father
Natasha later said she didn't know her
father though and a deleted scene from
Civil War she did say she found their
graves
two little gravestones by a chain-link
fence
Ivan could refer to Ivan Petrovich Gazoo
called from the comics a pre Red Room
Buster father and mentor figure who
later comes back in some weird ways
after her death the five surviving og
Avengers reflect the five stages of
grief over Natasha
Thor's in denial Hulk's always angry
Clint wishes he could bargain his own
life for hers Steve is just distraught
going through depression but Tony is
closest to acceptance do we know she had
family Tony's already moving on asking
about her family because that is his
fear over dying leaving pepper and
Morgan behind which is why it's so
important that Pepper tells them right
before he dies we're gonna be okay you
can Reza Tony
assembles the stone into a right-handed
start gauntlet reflecting the shot of
his father tinkering with stone tech
back in cap one boo
there's a way to trigger roadie rocket
who you looking for this for volunteers
at first I'm the strongest Avenger okay
so this responsibility falls upon me
going his ego and ragnerok strongest
avenger burner
welcome strongest Avenger Oh what and so
banner fulfills his destiny but the
radiation is mostly gamma it's like I
was made for this immediately banner is
coated and sweat on his face and lips
and the stones energy courses up through
his body the mine stones yellow glows
except into his mind to link his mind
with all the stones in the moment he
snaps it is the red of the reality stone
on his temple and outlining his face
showing how the full remaking of reality
starts with that piece of this six-way
combination nebula brings back 2014
Thanos on the screen are the dates 2988
bc and 2009 eighty states that we never
saw them go to but 2988 BC was the year
of Odin's father Bors battle with the
Dark Elves the verse known appearance of
the reality stone and 2009 would have
been just after fury recruited stark for
the Avengers a possible time they could
have taken the tesseract from project
Pegasus Scotch shrinks at the last
second to survive Thanos's blast and
then shrunken down in the rebel visible
behind him is the back-up war machine
armor and that's how Scott was able to
get Rhodey in the new suit for when they
pop up later when Thor powers up his
shaggy beard weaves into this sick
thinking brain and as they confront
Panos
he holds stones in his hand looks like
six of them yeah the guys picking his
targets now Thor's first swing at Thanos
rightfully goes for the head well done
sir Thor also calls back his combo move
from the Avengers using lightning to
supercharge Tony's suits
Thanos to flex this by spinning his
blade around his handle a nod to the
goofy Thanos copter they notice gets the
upper hand drives the store breaker in
to Thor's chest payback for Thor doing
this to him and infinity war make that
real great face ah then this
[Music]
listen to the music here at the light
motif to win cap made his big leap of
faith in his first film
he's showing then that he was worthy and
that his budging of mill near an age of
ultron was really just to spare his
friends confidence as the director
confirmed i don't care what the
screenwriter say kappa bounces mule near
off his own shield creating this dome
shockwave against Thanos and every one
of caps hits goes for the head goes
certainly worthy until it cracks Thanos
his helmet and famous just rips it off
to clear his vision they a nose grabs
caps wrists instead of the me linear
handle he's able to stop the wielder but
not himself worthy to stop the weapon he
is of shattering caps shield fulfilling
Tony's nightmare imagery from age of
Ultron and when cap tightens it on his
arm you can see that his arm is injured
he's tightening the strap as a
tourniquet and the voice of Falcon calls
back caps line on your left actually win
Sam greets old cap later he does so on
his left
T'Challa also appears on caps left flank
as cap covered his left during their
opening charge and Wakanda the Ravagers
join from contracts thea and guardians
willing to including Howard the Duck
hope Van Dyne also buzzes in and her
portal is say me for her shrunken size
now there were a few VFX oversights here
in the wide shot cap shield is no longer
broken and one shot shows Doctor Strange
with the eye of agamotto back around his
neck despite it being crushed on Titan
and it never appears again during this
battle but you know who cares cap fixes
that dumb blue ball into the age of
Ultron ending Avengers Assemble in this
opening charge Peter swings from Scotts
giant hand which is a nice little detail
since the last time they saw each other
he tripped him up and when Scott breaks
through the line a few outriders get
kicked up with his giant boots during
the fight in the background mantis is
subdues a beast by putting it in a
trance she gives it a little kick in the
head she's awesome to watch in the
background Tony and Peter hug it out
what are you doing
oh this is nice
Peter's confused because he was taught
not to trust Tony hugs that's not a hug
I'm just grabbing the door for you yet
originally this battle was gonna be
structured kind of like the Saving
Private Ryan opening an initial charge
to a trench rattly point where everyone
regroups but that trench scene was
deleted and was reshot to this that
wasn't our only Time Machine anyone see
an ugly brown van out there Scott how
long you need to get that thing working
I like know Scott's van now shows up
blinking on Tony's HUD but this reshoot
led to the big VFX oversight that's been
going around the fact that normal-sized
Scott is hot wiring the van at the same
time that a giant self is shoving a
Leviathan through a portal probably to
hell now to be clear this is not hank
pym it's not Bill Foster it's just a
mistake but notice in that shot none of
fantasies drop shifts are left remaining
yet seconds later when Wanda lanes in
front of T'Challa the drop ships are
back in the background that's because
the shots at atala running with the
gauntlet with giant Scott in the
background those were all added later
when the whole gauntlet handoff was
reconfigured without the trench scene
put more callbacks great give it to me I
call back to their moments of a war we
haven't met yet I'm pleased I don't can
hope that we're on it captain and that
smile is a callback to ant-man the wasp
purity the cap needed helps Captain
America captain
cap it's it's what we call them if
you're a friend and behind them in the
upper left group saves rocket SAS later
on rocket returns the favor by jumping
on group to shield them during the final
charge a quick it's the kill stabbed on
Corvus glaive payback for Corvis killing
some bird or melash a an infinity ward
and a dr. streams confirms to tony that
this is the one victory future he did
foreseen how many ruin one also it is
the one that Tony said he owed strange
exclusion oh you wonder now he's got a
point this outcome wretch trembles his
finger which he has consistently done as
a reminder that his hands have never
fully healed physically
I like how Thor uses me only er to way
down Stormbreaker against Thanos so that
they don't be able to lift either of
them but then notice that Tony never
went through the gauntlet at the
beginning only Thanos he's not trying to
dive on the fumble he's trying to tackle
the player that's because he designed
his mark 85 nanotech to be compatible
with the gauntlet it's only moments Tony
makes contact with it notice this stones
stopped glowing because his nanobots
have begun the transfer is taking his
father's advice he's shaken not pollen
and silvestri he uses another musical
callback his one-way trip theme from
Tony self-sacrifice and the Avengers
I am inevitable
and for tony's big line there's a smudge
of wood on his forehead added between
the wide shot and then it's there in the
close-up that's because Robert Downey
jr. did multiple ad libbed reshoots of
this final line he had some hilariously
crass ones so here when they come in a
close-up for I am Iron Man
his makeup has been retouched of course
calling back his famous closing words
from the first Iron Man film I am Iron
Man Rocket was saved at the last second
they mixed in a subtle Wilhelm scream in
there and with all the nods do Back to
the Future Part 2 in this movie it can
also be a nod to that hologram shark
gasps vanos and his black order dust
with parallel visuals to infinity war
every moss tumbles towards a nose just
like Peter did to Tony Proxima midnight
cradles Corvus glaive the same way Wanda
held vision in the camera tracks around
Thanos his final steps these same
cinematography as his final steps and
infinity war and he staggers a bit
between his opening speech I know what
it's like to lose turns the legs to
jelly as he's really done in every
Avengers film Tony makes the sacrifice
play in the same battle that cap proved
himself worthy both Avengers proven each
other wrong you're not the guy to make
the sacrifice play everything special
about you me my bottle
Tony's funeral brings us back to the
heart that ignited this franchise and
open the door for all these others Drax
is wearing a shirt despite his sensitive
nipples Harley keiner is there the kid
from Iron Man 3
now Gamora is not there if you think
about it her 2014 self or even her 2018
self never really met Stark a deleted
scene showed her walking off when
everyone's kneeling the script suggested
that she dust it along with thanasis
forces Morgan stark tells happy that she
wants cheese spoken a nod to Tony
telling happy to stop her cheeseburgers
and Iron Man when he returned which
itself was a nod to Robert Downey jr.
saying Burger King saved his life
because made him so disgusted with
himself and his drug use in Peters high
school
there's a girl with a web pattern skirt
some claiming that she could be
Wednesday see it's not it's just an
extra who were a hot topic skirt thanks
for playing
cat tells Bucky don't do anything stupid
till I get back
how can i you're taking all the stupid
with you I'll call back to Capital One
don't do anything stupid until I get
back
how can I taking all the stupid with you
signaling that Bucky knew cap was not
going to be coming right back just like
Bucky didn't come back the same either
in that movie old cap is beautifully
performed in super sentimental like
Steve keeps his shield in an art
portfolio tying in his artists work that
we've done in stuff in the MCU it's a
sweet sweet plot hole that directly
contradicts the movies old world time
travel not affecting the timeline you
left I was barked at us three times via
exposition the directors and writers
came to even agree on how the hell this
was possible honestly it would have been
way better if we just jumped from Steve
disappearing to the Past not returning
and one freaking out but Bucky smiling
and then going directly to this movie's
perfect final scene the man out of his
time finally achieves his destiny of the
clock reset he always wanted that
raincheck dance that he and Peggy
promised each other you know I still
don't know how to dance
I'll show you how just be there
you'll have to band play something slow
the song here is it's been a long long
time popular in the late forties with
spouses returning for more but this
music is the same that be replayed in
caps home in Winter Soldier
[Music]
the directors later revealed that
Peggy's signature red hat from agent
Carter was placed on a chair just
outside of frame but it doesn't matter
because both faces here are detached
from their hero garb they're just two
soldiers who no longer have to fight
they can simply finally live our
infinity sorry watch now moves on to
spider-man far from home which will be
followed by my official ranking of all
MCU films and then folks we're gonna
move on to a real watch of Sam Raimi's
spider-man you can join our watch Long's
on discord by becoming a patriot at
patreon.com selection rock stars follow
me on instagram at EA vos follow new
rock stars and subscribe so that in a
couple days we can all together say Brad
yeah
[Music]